bonjour jean baptiste eyraud merci de
répondre à nos questions en direct sur
rtl ce matin
la trêve hivernale a donc pris fin vous
craignez des mesures d'expulsion
pourquoi parce que la crise sanitaire
aurait pu à fragiliser certains ménages
au point qu'il ne puisse plus payer leur
logement
oui alors là là attendez il ya un petit
décalage lorsque les ménages qui ont les
2,5 à 2,8 millions de ménages qui ont
rencontré des difficultés à payer leur
loyer ou leur prête à la fin du mois
vont être pour ceux qui se retrouvent en
impayés et qui vont avoir à faire face à
un bailleur particulièrement difficiles
ou à une banque particulièrement gérer
exigeantes ou intransigeante et bien les
procédures viendront à partir de cet
automne et vont s'étaler sur l'année
prochaine
les expulsions commenceront l'année
prochaine donc là ce qu'on a nous à
partir d'aujourd'hui
ces expulsions des jugements qui ont été
rendues l'année dernière et pour
lesquels les propriétaires des bailleurs
d'ailleurs puisque s'il s'agit bien de
bailleurs donc pas de propriétaires
occupants et bien les bailleurs font
pression pour obtenir d'exécution de ces
jugements d'expulsion alors il faut
entendre qu'il ya à peu près 35 milles
il ya eu en 2010 18 35 mille demandes
d'intervention de la police de la part
des bailleurs pour procéder à une
expulsion manu militari
on en a jamais compté autant dans notre
pays et qu'il ya eu effectivement 16000
à peu près six mille expulsions forcées
c'est à dire que les gens sont réveillés
un beau matin avec l'huissier la police
et qui frappe à la porte et qu'il aura
un intime d'ouvrir si j'ouvre pas 7 sur
8 qui a qui arrivent ils sont jetés
immédiatement sur le palier où dehors
dans la rue et
leurs affaires sont déménagés ou décès
de jeu - est fermé alors ce qu'il faut
bien entendre c'est que voyez on est sur
un processus qui durera à peu près
normalement la trêve dès la trêve des
expulsions prend fin le 1er avril et et
recommence de preuve le 1er novembre
donc on a à peu près trente et une
semaine qui s'écoule là au 11 juillet on
a quinze semaines qui se sont écoulées
et on en a c'est ce qui reste encore
pendant lesquelles ces messieurs où ces
messieurs dames vont pouvoir pour faire
leur triste besogne en fait c'est à dire
mettre des gens dehors dans un contexte
où on n'a jamais compté autant de
logements vides donc pardon dans un
contexte on n'a jamais compté autant de
jugements d'expulsion de personnes via
la rue et de personnes déjà dans la rue
voilà c'est ça c'est qu'on est face à
une crise du logement qui est
excessivement grave qui produit de plus
en plus de d'exclusion par le logement
qu'on a aujourd'hui près de 80 à parlons
près de 200000 sans abri on a plus de 4
millions de mal logés
on n'a jamais eu autant de demandeurs de
nous demander au gouvernement alors on
va très clairement on lui demande d'une
part de suspendre les expulsions ne dira
pas d'expulsion relogement ce que ne
fait pas le gouvernement parce que bon
on a entendu la nouvelle ministre du
logement dire oui pas d'expulsion s'il
n'y a pas une proposition de relogement
ou une mise à l'abri
une mise à l'abri ça veut dire quoi
c'est à dire qu'on met des gens pendant
une semaine quinze jours dans un hôtel
puis après démerdez vous donc si vous
voulez on les remet à la rue mais de
manière différée ccc tout ça c'est des
fausses promesses défaut engagement
c'est pour venir assure un peu l'opinion
et dire oui ou non on est des gens
corrects mais pas du tout on a en plus
dans un contexte où on a
av russie et continuer à rodez donc qui
menacent et on va mettre des gens à la
rue
nous on a rencontré si vous voulez faire
on sait que quinze familles qui ont reçu
ce qu'on appelle le concordat fortes
pluies qui donne qui doivent être foutu
dehors à partir d'aujourd'hui et voir la
semaine prochaine et pendant tout l'été
ça risque d'être dramatique alors
évidemment ce que nous appelons
aujourd'hui ce que nous demandons la
suspension des expulsions
c'est la mise en oeuvre des droits le
respect des droits des personnes sont
mal logées ou sans abri parce que
n'oublions pas qu'à partir de nos jour
d'hui également c'est la fermeture d'un
certain nombre de structures
d'hébergement
donc on va avoir pas mal de sans abri
qui vont être remis à la rue
et puis c'est aussi le début des
coupures d'énergie 670 mille coupures
aux réductions d'énergie ont été
effectués en 2019 selon le médiateur de
l'énergie
c'est à dire près de 2% de la population
on n'a jamais compté n'ont plus autant
de coupures d'énergie
donc on voit bien rodé dernière question
je me permets de vous couper pardon vous
parler évidemment des locataires qui ont
souffert pendant la crise sanitaire il
ya aussi certains petits propriétaires
ou bailleurs comme vous dites qu'ils ont
sous verre qu'est ce que vous leur
répondez si leurs locataires ne leur
paye pas leur loyer et s'ils peuvent se
retrouver eux également en difficulté
voilà il se retourne contre l'état ils
ne demandent une indemnisation et ils
auront droit à une indemnisation c'est
une jurisprudence constante les l'état
doit à des mises et lorsqu'il n'exécute
pas une un jugement d'expulsion
voilà explique emmanuelle wargon la
nouvelle un ministre du logement à agir
là dessus on va très bien très
clairement on demandait manu par contre
d'une part de suspens des expulsions de
suspens des coupures d'énergie de
laisser les sans abri dans des
structures d'hébergement de faire en
sorte que les plus personne dans la rue
de réquisitionner les logements vides 1
et enfin sur le fond il ya la question
du fond puisque jamais le logement était
aussi cher et jamais d'ailleurs les
milieux immobiliers nous gagner autant
d'argent
c'est à dire qu'il faut revenir sur la
réforme des apl augmenter les apl
baisser les loyers bien sûr parce que
les classes populaires souffrent
aujourd'hui du logement cher et puis
mener une vraie politique du logement
qui permettent de loger décemment de
manière stable de manière durable et en
respectant et évidemment nos
planète une politique du logement
coretti merci jean baptiste aéro d'avoir
répondu à nos questions je rappelle que
vous êtes le porte parole de
l'association droit au logement et on
manifeste tout à l'heure à 15h pas du
palais royal
le message est passé